foreign
and family law Committee of the house
first stop is House Bill 547 the chair
calls a representative testerman to
present his bill
at this time the chair can exercise the
prerogative of putting the bill into
play we will now be hearing on House
Bill 547 I have one
pink card that has made it this far
with looks like some more coming
and just to let everybody know are these
thank you these bills are scheduled at
45 minute intervals so if we have a
flurry or plethora of pink cards we will
have to uh hold you to the two minutes
you're asking for and maybe even give
you an extra minute so Bill
547 is now in play and the chair
recognizes Aaron is it jacenna
Justina
from New Hampshire legal assistance to
speak against
the bill and you asked for two minutes
and I'll give you free
there's one rule
okay oh I'm not either and I learned
I will start over good morning Mr chair
and members of the committee
my name is Aaron Jacina and I direct the
domestic violence advocacy project at
New Hampshire legal assistance we
represent low-income victims and
survivors of domestic violence sexual
assault and stalking in their High
lethality protective order cases and
family law cases including divorce and
parenting I am here today to testify in
opposition of House Bill 547 first I
just want to thank and appreciate the
sponsor for his efforts to make things
better and safer for victims of domestic
violence and their children in the
family court system
there are pieces of this bill that I
think are worth considering but
generally speaking this bill is a
complete overhaul of the parental rights
and responsibility statute that we
currently have which if this bill is
passed would dramatically change the
landscape of parental rights and
responsibilities in our state
and those could have some negative
consequences for victims and practically
speaking there are some things in this
bill which are not possible to implement
and I'm happy to go through the bill
line by line but I don't think even
within the three minutes that the
committee has time to hear of that but I
am happy to answer any questions that
you may have I'm also happy to be a
resource on the family court system at
another time if that's helpful to the
committee but quickly I would like to go
over some of the major issues that we
found were problematic with this bill
first this bill requires a parent who is
found to be abusive to have supervised
visitation with their children at a
supervised visitation center using a
metal detector I am fully supportive of
the use of supervised visitation centers
sadly we only have one left in our state
which is in Dover that uses a metal
detector and follows best practices
so practically speaking this would not
be a possibility for every parent who
has been found to abuse their partner or
their child to go to the one Center in
Dover
um secondly it requires the therapist to
essentially clear an abusive parent for
visitation
no therapist will in my experience or
should ever uh clear somebody for
um
or state whether or not somebody has the
potential to abuse in the future
lastly this bill requires a restraining
order to be entered in all cases with no
exceptions for co-parenting contact
again I'm supportive of the use of
marital and parenting restraining orders
but this would effectively elimit the
ability of parents to co-parent so it
says in all cases there shall be a
restraining order entered so that means
if the restraining order is in place and
there's no provision for contact between
the parents regarding the children that
let's say Johnny wants to go to a play
date at Chuck E cheese Dad can't contact
mom to say I will pick up Johnny at
Chuck E cheese at four o'clock it would
eliminate any contact between the
parties which again would make
co-parenting extremely difficult
um
again I I'm happy to answer any
questions these are the three major
issues that we saw with the bill there
are other issues so at this point we are
requesting the committee to vote in
expedient to legislate or at the very
least push to a study committee to
determine whether or not changes to our
parental rights and responsibilities
statute need to be made and if so what
those changes might be thank you for
your testimony
um Bill writing 101.
uh I see no co-sponsors so I do not see
collaborative effort at least in the
list of sponsors did the sponsor of the
bill reach out to you for your input
along the way no I'm going to ask that
of everybody who's going to come up and
speak
um to your knowledge was their access of
what other states do
I don't know any of the background
related to this bill we have 50 states
50 experiments in democracy we're not
the only ones who face this problem so
this is for anybody who cares to listen
collaborative efforts in terms of
asking me to ask the committee
researcher what do other states do is
always important any questions of uh
Miss Justina yes welcome back thank you
did you work last night I did not I
worked uh day shift yesterday you're all
sparkly and fresh that's correct thank
you Mr chairman
um I'm just wondering how they would
prove that domestic violence happened
that's that's one of the issues that I
have with this bill that you have to
prove and domestic violence can be very
difficult to prove agreed
um there are some Provisions to show
that abuse occurred
um under 173b or 169 C uh I can't say
whether it requires that somebody get a
domestic violence protective order and
as we know even if somebody doesn't get
a domestic violence protective order
that doesn't mean that they are not a
victim of domestic violence sometimes it
is not always the safest option for
somebody to seek a protective order
under 173b or 633 a which is our
stocking statute
sometimes in Family Court
um
people are able to testify to abuse that
has occurred whether that be verbal
emotional physical abuse and the court
is able to make a finding of abuse and
they will use that finding to determine
decision making and residential
responsibility
so it's unclear to answer your question
more directly it is unclear in this bill
what would be required in order to make
those findings which would then lead to
the supervised visitation and then a
therapist determining somebody is
cleared uh for future visitation
unsupervised
representative McMahon
yes thank you Mr chairman
um is it attorney Justina no I'm a
paralegal only then paralegal Ms Justine
although I am able to represent clients
in court now under the new rule that you
all and law that you came up with last
session so thank you very much you're
welcome
and that's not under appeal right it is
not okay I represented my first client
last Thursday congratulations thank you
um a question relative to
um the statement that's
written multiple times here rebuttable
presumption
my understand my personal understanding
on reading legalese is that that gives
would give the authority having
jurisdiction the judge the ability to
make a decision without having testimony
from each one or both parties is that
correct or what's your guidance on that
no I would believe that they would have
testimony from both sides um in a full
evidentiary hearing both sides will be
able to provide their testimony and then
the judge would make a decision one way
or the other it doesn't mean that they
can't provide evidence or testimony it's
just that would be essentially the
default and then somebody and then if
there was evidence to the contrary and
the judge made findings would be able to
make a different determination okay
thank you
representative thank you Mr chairman oh
I'm sorry I missed where exactly the
your three points are in the bill could
you tell me where those are
um I do I did not bring that up
thank you so much
okay so to the first point
um requiring um the parents to have
um
supervised visitation line 21
of page one
section five after if after a full
custodial hearing sure
is fine if I just okay
um the court order supervised the
visitation it shall order that such
visitation shall take place only at a
visitation center using a metal
detection device
it is also on page two
um section lines 31 through 37.
uh my second Point requiring a therapist
to essentially clear and clear is my
word uh is on page one
lines 13 through 19.
I think it was in another section as
well I'm just quickly looking
foreign
and then uh the piece about the
restraining order is on page four
lines 26
um through
36 and then it goes on to page five
and there are some repetitive sections
in the bill as well so this may be
repeated
um in other places in the Bell
any other questions
saying none thank you for your testimony
thank you very much I appreciate your
time
and by the way I took the practice LSAT
section on children and family law and
aced it so maybe we can go to law school
at night together
chair recognizes Randall Collier
to come up and speak
please sir no you have you have now
three minutes we're into the
three-minute rule here and I enforce it
so if you have a story to tell be brief
thank you committee and the chair my
name is Randall Collier
um I have a lot of problems with with
this bill
um
primarily
I have a lawsuit pending because of
these statues
um
and a lot of them don't make any sense
whereas it seems that the family court
judge it's an equity court and the only
the only way to actually take your
rights away is to
be in a criminal court in a criminal
proceeding with Jerry by appears and
three elements to a crime
um and to the ladies speaking about
um the evidence of being a victim of
domestic violence you're right you know
it's hard to tell
um however
um you know when testimony contradicts
evidence and the judge goes with the you
know testimony it's hard for for someone
to rebut
um being found under a criminal statue
but not actually in a criminal court so
there's obviously a conflict interest
using criminal statues uh not in a
criminal
Court thank you
next time you come back I owe you one
minute and 55 seconds extra thank you
sir that very succinct and much
appreciated and Dana Albrecht Mr
Albrecht
thank you Mr chair Dana Albrecht Nashua
New Hampshire I have some exhibits you
can look at them later just in support
uh I'm strongly opposed to this bill is
written it relies on uh RSA 173b
uh which at this time I believe is an
unmitigated disaster in practice
as actually implemented right now
uh it's an Unholy obligation of civil
and criminal law where the defendant has
is subject to all the penalties of
criminal law and none of the protections
traditionally afforded a criminal
defendant
in particular no right to an attorney
uh RSA 173 B
uh right now is essentially used in two
capacities
again in practice
uh one is to issue legitimate orders of
protection that are badly needed
uh and we hope the victims get those
sometimes they don't
uh and the other is that it is often
used by plaintiffs acting in extremely
poor Faith to gain the system
uh
to uh to that point of a gaming the
system
I have just two examples for you here
a number exhibit a is a pending court
case up at the New Hampshire Supreme
Court uh cbvak docket 2022-0463
uh
and from that we have a letter from the
defendant in jail
it may not uh go down in history like
Gideon V Wainwright or Martin Luther
King's letter but it's definitely worth
reading I'd encourage you to do that
uh he's been there since December 20th
and uh his position is all he's done
wrong is send a non-petroning test text
message about parenting to their child's
mother and he's still in jail for that
and you have one minute left
um
exhibit B we have a case where somebody
wants to game the system
can uh we have a registered sex offender
here who went in as the plaintiff and
basically got
judge Lemaire to
give him an order of protection
and not sure how that happened mistakes
were made
but she's given some great testimony
before this committee before so
also
gaming the system here so I would in
conclusion just suggest that we would
really need a complete overall of 173b
before even
going anywhere with a bill of this
nature thank you very much so much any
questions Mr Albrecht just want to tell
you my mind usually shuts down around
minute four and so everybody's been very
good I've listened to everything
everybody said so far thank you thank
you chair recognizes Vivian Gerard
she asked for two minutes I'm going to
give you free
thank you chair and members of the
committee I just wanted to speak today
quickly
um because a lot of the things that you
guys are discussing in this bill I
really disagree with because just a
quick story here my ex tried to put a
false police report on me so I could
lose my children he's still trying to
fight Soul custody with my children
and he will try to find any way possible
to try to put a domestic violence not
only on me but he's constantly
constantly trying to go around the
system
to get sole responsibility of my
children and I have Primary Residential
so passing this bill I just wanted to
say that it really should be
reconsidered and looking at some of the
the verbiage in here I just really
disagree with that's all thank you so
much any questions
seeing none the chair now recognizes
Richard head that's Attorney Richard
head right
attorney head it is yes well graduate
school in England I stand on ceremony
okay Richard is fine too though thank
you
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Richard head I'm
the government Affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch I do want to just
point out some some aspects of this bill
that are problematic in terms of how
they can be implemented
um some of it's definitional I won't go
in into a lot of the details there's the
bill uses the term Family Violence
that's not that's not a specifically
defined term so if we take the
definition of family and the definition
of violence within sort of the domestic
violence context it's a fairly broad
term I think although although not
specifically defined so it would be
subject
to some level of interpretation as to
what is intended by Family Violence but
that may have some fairly broad scope
and then the implications as it flows
through this bill as you've already
heard and I won't repeat become very
broad
um
we agree with the with the point of uh
Aaron Justina regarding the the
um visitation centers he would become uh
sort of a functional
um ban
um based on the fact that there's only
one supervision Center that meets the
criteria uh in the state
the other aspect of the bill is it
creates prohibitions based on Family
Violence but it doesn't give a time
frame so it doesn't say when the Family
Violence may have may have occurred what
circumstances may have have related to
it
um and and
um so there's there's no sort of
consideration in the bill for
um discretion with the with the court to
evaluate all the facts and circumstances
and to establish an order that that
meets the needs of an abused victim the
children and the parents so
um the the phrasing of the bill is
frequently in the context of shall it
creates a an absolute mandate without
exceptions
um as and as an example of that on page
two beginning at line 31
talking about and determining parental
rights and responsibilities
created presumption that the presence of
of child abuse under 169 C or domestic
violence creates a rebuttable
presumption and it goes on
and again doesn't talk about time frame
or any attenuating circumstances or sort
of a a what is the nature of the balance
where where it becomes somewhat more
problematic is in the uh going from page
two line 36 if there are two instances
of continued abuse in or around the
exchange of the supervised visitation of
the child
under the statutes the court shall
suspend visitation altogether and again
it's a mandate without sort of an
evaluation of the of the of what's going
on and it's not clear
exactly as to how that would be
presented to the court the way it's
phrased
um
so there is because of the absolute
mandate
stated in here there is a risk as you
heard from some of the other testimony
about the statute becoming weaponized
and and the
um in in in the allegations there may be
an encouragement to create an allegation
um because the statute as written
creates a uh an absolute requirement of
shall suspend in that then you know sort
of becomes a process within within a
case
um my last uh
point is
um all right two more points I apologize
page two beginning at line one inserts a
new uh introduction to paragraph Roman
one it is essentially the exact same
thing with with a statutory change as
paragraph three which would be deleted
once you start moving paragraphs around
within a statute you then have a sort of
a carry along of every time a section is
referenced
that needs to follow along if we have a
form that references it that needs to
sort of get changed and it becomes sort
of an unnecessary complication when all
you're doing is changing a word within
the within the section my last point is
more or less an educational Point I've
made this point a lot last session I've
had to do it fewer times this session
is the effective date and it says 60
days after passage there's a statute
which I handed out
um
and you may hear me reference it
relative to other other bills RSA 14
colon 9-a is a statute that governs
effective dates it has a very specific
requirement relative to anything that
affects judicial processes essentially
um and it says that they shall become
effective on January 1 on the January 1
following passage and that's under RSA
14 colon 9-a paragraph Roman 2 small a
so any of these bills that impact the
judicial branch that have an effective
date other than January 1 we just ask
that those get changed with that I would
conclude my testimony I'd be happy to
answer any questions any questions for
attorney head I have one did these Prime
sponsor only sponsor of the build
consult you in any way while crafting
this bill um thank you for the question
no we did not hear from the prime
sponsor thank you anyone else thank you
for your testimony thank you
and the chair now calls Pamela kylig
I was going to say pardon the French but
it's German
three months in Germany okay yeah no not
many people get that on the first try so
thank you
um good uh good morning uh Mr Tara
members of the committee my name is
Pamela kylig and I am the public policy
specialist at the New Hampshire
Coalition against Domestic and Sexual
Violence
um the Coalition as some of you might
know is the umbrella Organization for 12
community-based crisis centers who
provide free and confidential services
to nearly 15 000 survivors of sexual and
domestic violence annually I'm here to
speak and I'll keep it brief because I
Echo the concern shared by attorney head
and Aaron Jacina we oppose the bill as
written and because of the significant
changes it would make to the statute
um we really appreciate the sponsors
sponsors efforts to recognize the
importance of protecting victims and
their children when determining parental
rights and responsibilities in domestic
violence cases however
um while there are some positive things
that could come from this legislation we
are really concerned about some
significant unintended consequences that
could come that could be at the
detriment of victims and their children
and we find it really important to
strike the right balance in the law so
we would just ask the committee to
consider at the very least allowing us
to further study what changes could be
made if there are any to ensure that the
appropriate protections are in place but
at this time we find the bill in
expedient to legislate and would like
you to consider that as well
will you take questions
um absolutely thank you any questions
did the sponsor consult with you
um no okay thank you
and that concludes the uh hearing the
testimony thank you so much
with the approval of ranking member I
close the hearing on Bill 547 and now
open the executive session on the bill
while we have the last handout coming
around
okay
all right
okay folks before I'm ready to entertain
a motion just anybody's thoughts on the
build before us anybody wanna
hand up and share something
I think representative Bickford does
okay
um he's getting ready
language that they're working with here
this language that we put together in
2005 from the family law task force and
they're looking to be looked at to amend
that and I have to agree I'm I'm not
favorable to it after
just reading it uh you may be going too
far and yeah it sure will weaponize
things
um
that's my estimation I didn't hear
anything about the guardian lighting
list I
was sort of interested in how that might
uh play out
um
I I do wish we could exec it a different
time because
um
people write in up till noon time
to send us information on these things
and we're not getting the opportunity to
look at those things that's my little
protest
okay
anyone else any thoughts about the bill
before us
I hear from other committee chairs that
their members talk too much
oh because you listen better
thank you
well my thoughts there was no
consultation with either the executive
department or judicial Department
relative to the bill
there were no co-sponsors so it hasn't
seemingly been hashed out with other
legislators willing to put their name on
it
there's no documentation of what other
states do
sponsor even is not present besides
being noticed in the calendar I sent out
an email to ahead of the calendar to
people letting them know when their bill
will be heard
I think it's not just one but maybe two
bridges too far there's good stuff in it
and even everyone who spoke here
thoughts so uh this is the kind of uh
situation where I'm very tempted to say
let's sit on this for a bit and rewrite
it except this is an early bill and it's
got to get out the door fairly quickly I
don't think there's time to rewrite an
amendment big enough
to consult with everybody and get the
research and and Deuce the things that
would make us have a good uh possible
Amendment and if it's big enough it
might be arguably in part non-germaine
which means the speaker has to rule on
it and so on so we have a clock issue as
well
um
I would entertain
um I would entertain a motion I think
you know where I'm going I can make the
motion I'd rather not would somebody
care to make a motion
can we make a motion to Ito
representative Levesque I saw your hand
you're making a pointer motion right
okay yes
I'm just gonna Echo what representative
Perez said I was going to make a motion
to ITF all right we have a motion from
representative Moulton
to itl do I hear a second
and the second was representative
Greg excuse me chair chairman I was the
one who made the motion to Ito you did
yes
like I I had my hand and I say can we
ask you I'm sorry that's okay though I
don't hear Spanish quite as well but I'm
working on it as you know I can roll my
Arts that's okay okay so that was
representative Perez I misread where
your finger was pointing I apologize for
that
or not
okay that's fine so Mr chairman
as the
over here
has the policy changed about starting
with a positive yes good and so
therefore you have been rehabilitated
from doing it the first time yeah they
did change that okay
so representative Perez moves and who
seconded it representative Moulton and
you're in the on Deck Circle for another
bill okay good
thank you
and the rule as you know is you get to
write the committee report
making a motion and if it needs to be
defended from the floor you get first
dibs on that which doesn't mean you have
to do it but it means if you want to
go for it I have to turn that
information in any further discussion on
this
when the clerk is ready please call the
roll the motion on House Bill 547 is itl
moved by representative Perez and
seconded by representative Moulton
foreign
chairman Pierce
not present chairman Pearson I apologize
that's okay I've been calling you
personnel and I don't think that's
correct that's my Plano
we'll go out after
um
the motion is itl yes chairman Pearson
to itl yes
representative long yes
representative DeSimone
representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yeah representative ball yes
representative Panic is
not present representative Seidel yes
representative Grossman is not present
representative Levesque
yes
representative Petrino votes yes
representative Perez
yes representative Greg yes
representative Moulton yes
representative Raymond yes
the vote is 14 to zero with two not
present
objection to going on consent
seeing hearing none thank you very much
this concludes the exact session on
House Bill 547.
at 10 15
we will
take up house bill 600.
Pierce
actually leave them at the end of the
table and they will bring he will bring
them forward
representative Bickford will
foreign
now open the hearing on House Bill 600
and act relative to temporary orders for
parental rights and responsibilities the
chair recognizes the prime sponsor
representative testerman
seeing that the prime sponsor is not
here the chair now recognizes Attorney
Richard head from the judicial branch to
speak to this bill
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Richard head I'm
the government Affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch a couple sort of
constructive construction
comments relative to this uh would the
attorney please uh hold for a second I
need a State Rep to introduce the bill
you can stay right there so uh
would you like to do that
oh yield to chair for a second
I'll introduce House Bill 600 relative
to temporary orders for parental rights
and responsibilities thank you very much
Mr Vice chairman
and now
see this is why I have people smarter
than me it's the only way it's good to
have a team it is
um thank you again Mr chairman Richard
head government Affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch
um just a couple comments about this
bill one so page one line five it's a
short bill
says temporary hearing orders shall be
held within 30 days we don't know how
you hold an order so we're not quite
sure what the intent of the sponsor was
there are relative to your question but
the last bill we did not receive any
requests for input from the sponsor
um it relates to again and then going on
30 days after the filing
um
a a petition that gets filed still has
to be served there has to be process
um frequently you see
um uh dates from Return of service for
example so that all the parties now have
noticed that they uh that there's a
proceeding and that a hearing is going
to be scheduled
the the time frames are not necessarily
cons so this relates to temporary orders
um and talks about the after filing of a
petition concerning a minor child the
court and then it says shall issue
orders instead of a May taking away that
discretion from the court with such
conditions and limitations it's not
consistent with some of the other
Provisions within RSA 461a such as 461 a
colon 9 which talks about ex parte
temporary orders requires a hearing
within five days so that does fit
however it's only if there is a specific
request for a hearing ultimately there
may not be a request for a hearing this
bill would mandate a hearing where the
parties do not actually necessarily want
one or have not requested one
um it's also inconsistent with
461-8 colon 9. um which talks about 30
actually not necessarily inconsistent
but that's an example of of where we
have 30 days from service
we do have concerns generally about
bills there are a number of bills this
session that impose mandatory deadlines
on the court for hearings we have
one of our most valuable assets is our
docket we have a docket that every judge
has it cannot be longer than seven and a
half hours while the court is open and
they get filled and we're talking about
circuit court so we're talking about
Family Division cases and District
division cases and they fill a docket
and they're as we add more and more
mandatory hearings into our docket
that creates fewer openings for all of
the cases that don't have a strict
mandatory deadline and there are a large
number of of statutory constitutional
Provisions that set requirements so that
then ends up creating just significant
operational limitations from for courts
Court staff and the judges to implement
or or to put together a daily docket
so we do have significant concerns about
any time we we start putting in
mandatory 30-day 45-day deadlines and
without sort of exceptions if the
parties ask for more time it's not
allowed for in here if the parties
um have some sort of have a have a
mutual agreement they don't need
hearings that's not accounted for
hearing in this in this process so
there's just a a lot of
things that have Ripple effects in the
system that have not been contemplated
in this bill and we think that just in
and of itself creates some some
significant operational problems for the
from the Court's perspective with that
I'll conclude my comments but would be
happy to take any questions
any questions for attorney head
representative Raymond
thank you Mr chairman and uh thank you
attorney head for taking my question and
to Mr chairman for noticing my lien
trying to get around the corner here my
question is regarding
um situations where
um service is not happening so where a
party has filed in court and then
um they've attempted to uh serve the
other party and it it doesn't work what
typically happens then and would this
bill make any changes to that because as
I was reading it I was thinking that
might be where this person was trying to
go with the bill
um so I don't read it that it would make
changes
um to the service aspect of of so
problematic service where person has
moved we don't know where they are
necessarily or whatever maybe limiting
service it would be a request to the
court for alternative service so
publication something else
um but there there would be sort of a
process that would go before the judge
just asking for alternate native service
and and and I apologize to take another
Point anytime the courts receive
requests for temporary orders they are
evaluated in terms of is there an
emergency situation is there a
circumstance where speed is appropriate
and that's one of the factors the court
would take into account so if there's a
Need for Speed the court will will
schedule stuff quickly
um and and if the need is there in less
than 30 days so I'm not saying that
these are not important
orders but the the sort of strict
deadlines without consideration of the
consequence of the of the circumstances
creates sort of an unnecessary burden
um anytime we're dealing with temporary
orders those tend to be sort of the
higher priority
um types of requests within the system
but they don't all need necessarily to
be heard within a strict deadline
any further questions
I'm just reading ahead in the 461
section here and it looks like it
expands on what you're saying is if
speed is necessary speed is possible
speed is absolutely possible and I I
should have just started with that I
have it in my mind it's just implied and
I forget to vocalize things sometimes
but there is language already about
exercising you know appropriate speed
and it is it is no you know the clerks
do that when they receive these these
types of of requests so it's it's built
into the system already
um it but but the lack of discretion
either by the parties or the court sort
of creates unnecessary limitations and
burdens
I think you'll understand we Face much
the same thing in scheduling and moving
bills through absolutely absolutely
thank you so much thank you and the
chair recognizes Vivian Gerard she says
she wants to speak for one minute in
opposition to the bill
thank you chair members of the admittee
um I have to strongly agree with um
Richard head on this one because when
you're throwing a 30-day limit in the
court systems as we all know speed does
not equal Court
um if a judge is supposed to be getting
an order out in 30 days we can't even
get that out of them so how are they
going to come up with a 30-day window on
a temporary
hearing and all those other cases like
myself I've been in the court system for
nine years so that just keeps bumping
other cases like mine where you don't
get an answer and the only people that
suffer is the family and the children
thank you
any questions
seeing none thank you so much and Mr
Randall Collier welcome back
representing yourself in opposition to
the bill needs three minutes to speak
thank you committee and the chair and
let me uh speak in opposing this bill uh
461 A8 uh just kind of curious I agree
with the uh other speakers uh regarding
the time frames
um if anyone's ever been on the other
side of this uh waiting 30 days or even
45 days or
any amount of time to be without your
kid
um is detrimental to their well-being as
well as the parent
um
understanding it says the orders may be
issued ex parte I'm kind of confused how
the due process and the evidence to
defend if if it's an ex parte in one
party is not there to represent and
defend themselves
seems unconstitutional to put that in
there and I'll take any questions
is attorney had in the building
um we've we could take a continuing
education moment to could we explain
your question his question about ex
parte and some of those little nuances
of law
and thank you thank you for raising that
point
um thank you Mr chairman just and I'll
talk generally about ex parte requests
um next parte request is typically filed
with a court where
um circumstances may be so urgent that
there's insufficient time to bring the
other party into the uh into the court
to provide them notice opportunity to be
heard but circumstances are such that on
that day a party is looking for some
sort of uh relief from the court whether
it be protection whether whatever it may
be
it may be relative to access to Children
you know broad scope of potential issues
that may appear before the before the
court on a ex-bar team meaning no notice
to the other side and the court would
review that particular request they may
or may not ask him for more information
if the pleading is insufficient and in
order would get issued and if the order
is to Grant the motion for ex parte
relief the court also then would be
scheduling a hearing typically within
five days to allow for the party to get
notice it may be even shorter and an
opportunity to come in and provide
their version their view of of the facts
and circumstances and then the court
would reevaluate its ex parte order now
that's had an opportunity to hear from
from all the parties it may or may not
issue a a new modified or or withdraw
the order depending on the additional
facts that it may learn
ex parte simply meaning by the part one
party is present the other is not
exactly I mean it's just the filing
party the other party may not even know
that that there's a request filed at
that point
good any further questions during our
continuing education session Vice
chairman long
thank you Mr chairman uh I mean we we do
get numbers on parenting petitions and
all that I I'm wondering if there is
there a number of how many of these EX
parte's with no notice
uh in a qualification that it is five
days and it's not 10 or 20. it is five
days it is at least so so it depends on
the statute so if we're talking about
under 461a it's five days okay so so
just the number of how many of these
under 461. where there's no notice I
will check if we if we if it pops out of
if we can extract it and I'll send an
email to the committee thank you
uh stipulating that the prime sponsor
may have a point
um
and also stipulating that the difficulty
is as you had said what is a possible
Third Way
to see what would we need to do to honor
the speed that is requested in the bill
and yet make it possible without
inconveniencing others as Mr Rod pointed
out is there a possible remedy down the
road in your opinion so I guess I I'm
unsure as to whether there's a problem
in the first place
um I I don't know of I'm not sure what
the problem is we're trying to address
in order to put language in that that
fixes it because I think as appropriate
we are scheduling hearings quickly there
you know to the extent there are delays
it tends to be because
the docket day seven and a half hours
for that judge is just full and we're
trying to put it in
um if it needs to be we will
there some parties May view theirs as
needing and in fact you know 40 days may
be sufficient or nobody's requested
anything we don't need to and the
parties have an agreement
we don't want to hold a hearing fill up
a docket time when all of the parties
have filed a stipulation of agreement
um so I I you know
I don't so I to your question I don't
know what the exact problem is we're
trying to address in terms of of
scenarios that could then translate into
policy language
thank you
and thank you for our continuing ed
session thank you and I think we may
need a few more in the course of the day
to fill up the time we're here and uh
make some notes and let's see what we
can do
you got it chair recognizes Dana
Albrecht he asked for one minute he is
in support of the bill
maybe this can answer part of our
question
how about I say I Dana Albright for the
record how about if I say I'm in strong
support of the bill with appropriate
language cleanup to address a lot of the
concerns
uh by case has dragged on for six and a
half years I currently have an appeal
docket
2022-0517 raising claims of
unconstitutional delay
over going over two and a half years
without getting a hearing on a simple
motion for enforcement
most parents don't have the luxury of
kind of doing that though so I think we
really do need to get into statute
some kind of
language to implement uh reasonable time
frames to get uh parenting petitions
done
uh in particular I point out that uh all
DV requests actually happen ex parte
with no notice and have to be heard
within 30 days
and if we're doing DB petitions
why can't we do something similar for
parenting
and
at the moment that creates even a bigger
problem because as mentioned earlier
certain unsavory plaintiffs might wish
to use the DV mechanism
to kind of do an end run around all of
this and
get some of the things that this bill I
believe is meant to have happened the
right way and they get to do that the
wrong way and that's about all I'll say
if I'll take questions if there are any
seeing hearing none thank you so much
and I just under the wire another pink
card you
could you recognize me just briefly get
rid of the ex parte language thank you
thank you
I was reading I was reading exactly this
point Come on come up and
and thank you Mr chairman and and Aaron
Justina uh Justina corrected me and
she's absolutely right so what I testify
two is it's five days for
um ex parte it's five days if requested
30 days if the request is not received
so my mistake and I apologize for that
that's 461 A9 Roman free and following
that's correct I think that's right but
well I have the book so I haven't I
don't have it in front of me so that's
correct I'll I'll rely on that but so I
apologize for the error
thank you for the correction thank you
this closes the hearing on House Bill
600 and I now open the exact session
with the agreement of the ranking member
on House Bill 600.
I'd like to have a little sense of the
meeting discussion before I receive a
motion so
um
I'd like to speak
representative Moulton thank you Mr
chairman I do agree with the first
person that spoke I forget
who I forget what his name was but
regarding that there's there's
other deadlines like the person needs to
be served and you don't necessarily know
what the parenting plan needs to say
until the time has elapsed and you've
kind of
fleshed out some of the issues
um
you do need that time so these short
time frames while they might provide
some level of benefit it might end up in
incomplete temporary parenting orders
and that might end up elongating the
process in the long run
thank you anyone else wish to speak
on the committee so
yes representative D Simone
three that has been referenced in this
uh
469- a colon 9 sub-roman III if
temporary orders are made ex parte the
party against whom the orders are issued
May file a written request with the
clerk of the court and request a hearing
thereon such a hearing shall be held no
later than five days after the request
is received by the clerk
thank you Mr chairman may I speak you on
one condition is that you turn on your
microphone please
you're welcome sometimes I use my mama
voice and don't think I need one anyway
I think that
46983 blah blah it already answers to
this
so I thank you
back for more representative Moulton
thank you Mr chairman so ex parte is
that they if you if you know
um repti Simone that ex parte you do
that it's just one side
okay thank you
Mr chairman representative Bickford oh
thank you Mr chairman
um
these bills that we have today uh seem
to be entering into the realm of the
machinations of the court of which I
don't really know the details of how the
court needs to file etc etc and I would
before I could
pass these I would want to have a
minimum subcommittee to help me
understand like you need somebody from
judiciary
to uh
augment or help understand
the problem that we're trying to solve
so one of the Motions that we may
consider is the motion to retain which
means we hold on to this
uh individuals may meet I may appoint a
subcommittee and in the fall we come
back and consider based on that group of
people's work I hope in consultation
with the Judiciary so retain is a motion
we don't have to pass it we don't have
to kill it we can keep it so just for
when it's time to make a motion that
would that speak to what you just said I
think so it is also in terms study you
want to retain that would be a
subcommittees thing it could be I've
kind of forgotten the
the various ways well it kind of yeah
yeah anyway I'm stuck with that I
I just don't know enough about the
system to be able to make an intelligent
decision on this
I might suggest to those of you
considering writing bills for next time
you do that work up front there's a lot
of prep work before you start to see the
grounds floor of a skyscraper they go
down several floors to build the
foundations that's the foundation of
good bill writing is to check with the
people who know to ask the questions
that need to be asked to have them give
information we didn't know how to ask
but given that that may not have
happened here I don't know
we can keep it ourselves and do that
work if we wish
anyone else
yes representative Vice chairman long
thank you Mr chairman
um with respect to retaining
I mean it's difficult to know what the
intent is when you don't when the
sponsor is not giving you what the
intent is it may be a good intent I
don't know what it is but we have to
remember that if we retain this
this becomes our bill it is our bill now
sir we do and we do what we want with it
and you know is that what we want to do
as a committee start taking bills and
sort of twisting and turning them as to
where we think they ought to be going so
um
you know as the chairman mentioned that
you know there is a due diligence
process that gives us the information
and even if we were to retain it I don't
even know what the intent of the bill is
so where would I stocked
um so what's that if I'm not mistaken
once the bill has been assigned to this
committee it is no longer the sponsor's
bill it is our bill
so we can do with it as we wish we can
change it as we wish this is a platform
for our going somewhere and we really
don't necessarily need to know what the
sponsor's intent and we can ask we don't
have to we can take it and make it
something should we choose to
and that's a little work group and it
reports back when we come back in
September October and then we decide
what to do and on it goes on its merry
way till next year
any other questions
any thoughts anybody wish to make let me
ask you this before we do it because
it's easier to do it when we're not
doing it officially
um
how does the idea of retain and work on
it strike you this is not an official
vote but it's a sense of the group
I don't see hands
do I see hands for retaining
okay do I see hands for passing the bill
okay you know what's left the chair will
entertain a motion
over here in the corner okay and I owe
you a second yes represented I like to
do it bipartisan but well that's okay
we're all friends uh the emotion is uh
from representative Raymond and the
motion is uh regretfully itl I just
don't think it's good okay uh no you you
you're in next I owed her for one from
last time remember uh do I have a second
I knew it I'll second it
I know you will
okay and and we'll remember you for next
time okay got it oh you've done this
before give the freshmen some fun right
any further discussion
the assistant Clerk
will call the roll on
House Bill 600 the motion is itl uh
moved by representative Raymond seconded
by representative Greg with the
assistant clerk now please call the roll
if you want itl it's a yes or an i if
you don't like itl it's an A or a no
chairman Pearson yes
Vice chairman long yes
representative DeSimone yes
representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
panic
oh sorry absent
representative Seidel yes
representative Grossman that's an absent
too sorry I can't see down there
representative Levesque yes
representative Richard no yes
representative Perez
yes yes
representative Greg yes representative
Moulton yes representative Raymond yes
so that is going to be 14 years two or
not here
so the itl
fourteen to zero and any objections to
consent
and before we leave today if I may have
the committee reports aka the blurb from
representative Raymond
this concludes the executive session on
House Bill 600 and we will reconvene at
11 o'clock on House Bill 404.
all right actually who knows how to
write a blurb that's it we don't have a
Minority Report I immediately regret my
decision
[Laughter]
um
do I do it in word or can I just send an
email yes over here
no no it's a majority okay
um
last year what I did to make it easier
before
thieves
opening the hearing for House Bill 404
and act relative to support contempt
hearings the chair recognizes
representative testerman to present his
bill
the chair recognizes Vice chairman
Pat long to present the bill
thank you Mr chairman
four relative to support contempt
hearings
thank you sir
chair recognizes Dana Albrecht
foreign
who asks for a minute
you do not say in your pink card whether
you're referred or again it
turn your mic on oh thank you
forgive me uh Dana Albrecht I believe
the intent of this bill like the one we
just heard or one of the intents is to
ensure that things that need to happen
in Family Court proceedings happen in a
timely fashion and I think that that
intent
is a extremely laudable goal and I think
that's something that the committee
should try to do right now we have a
hundred percent of DVS that are handled
in an ex parte fashion no notice to the
other party while other stuff can
languish on the docket so I just
encourage the committee to vote at a
minimum to retain something
uh is a vehicle just to make sure we get
things done in family court in a timely
fashion uh and that's all I have on this
unless there's questions
any questions
saying none thank you
chair recognizes Vivian Gerard
and she says three slash four I'm going
to say that's three to four minutes not
45 seconds three or four minutes correct
got it
thank you chair and members of the
committee
um so this one actually has a very
strong
I guess
it leaves it leaves a strong effect here
because if you're allowing people to do
non-payment for child support filed by
the other parent what happens when you
have a parent that intentionally
short pays the child support arrears
every month so for instance if I brought
my ex in there because child support
hasn't been taken out the full amount
and he just kind of pays what he wants
when he feels like it
um I I don't understand
how that really can play into effect and
as far as being able to go
schedule like a mediation
these arrears should not be up for
debate what they owe they owe
and I noticed in the past because of my
own case a lot of these
um arrears
once they go up for appeals they
actually disappear
again something else that I don't
understand so if somebody has all these
Escape goats all the way around to get
away from paying their child support
especially when somebody makes a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars a year and
he's taken extravagant vacations and
buying extravagant property
I mean this actually does cause a very
big strain on children
so having the your numbers for arrears
being mediated
um it just doesn't seem like that makes
sense I mean that's going to be
um violating some kind of federal law
here for the child support
um I I was looking at the um the RSA 461
A14 that you're referencing here but it
seems like
that is already written into the law
so why should it get mediated if
somebody willfully does not want to pay
their child support payments and why is
people not being held accountable so if
you have working class people that are
making a true
um effort to pay their child support
why are they being held to the highest
standard when you have a white collar
person like my ex
um that he has no ramifications for not
pain and support
so here we are now looking at former
judge intercasso she owes the the state
seventy eight thousand dollars in her in
her settlement nobody's holding her
accountable for her debts that is still
a state debt so why are all these
um a rear is just getting forgiven and
just kind of getting pushed off the
books
my ex is the only person I've ever met
that the arrears go away
and and this is a true problem here we
are struggling to support the family and
somebody just can walk over and mediate
their arrears
from what I understand arrears should
never go away
um I do have uh some handouts that I'd
like to give to you guys because I I
strongly believe that numbers speak a
thousand words and where you're looking
at two different income class people and
looking at the arrears and their form of
payments I think that this will really
give you an eye-opener of what the child
support Bureau does and one of the
concerns
um somewhat unrelated to this bill is
the fact that why are they not
collecting based on the the court orders
why are they collecting what they feel
like and not following the court orders
and why all those arrears
not being calculated properly so I do I
do want to pass this out and I I would
like to find out how
multiple people are not being treated
equally
thank you for your testimony uh both
oral and written and are there any
questions
representative D Simone
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question are you for or
against this bill
I am against the Bill thank you ma'am
if you could hand that to representative
Bickford your stash of handouts please
any further questions
saying none will await her written
testimony
foreign
I think so
yes yeah
chair recognizes Mr Randall Collier
foreign
who signs in also in opposition to the
bill
thank you chair and committee and
Randall Collier thank you for the
opportunity to oppose this bill today I
oppose this bill uh in in direct
um
contradiction to uh trucks for verse
Granville 530 us 57 year 2000 in case
we're Supreme Court of the United States
citing constitutional right of parental
rights to the director upbringing the
children struck down in Washington state
law aloud any third party to petition
the state courts for visitation rights
and parental objections unless
um
unless obviously in a court of law
illegal search and seizure for child
support
um has to have due process
um and speaking to the lady behind me
um just to help her
um about the payments of Child Support
the way I understand reading all the
federal rules that if you cash a check
for payment then that's a payment it may
not be in full but that is a payment for
child support and if it's cash then it's
a legal tender I don't know her case but
I just wanted to speak on that so anyway
I just wanted to oppose the bill for
child support and arrears as Supreme
Court ruled down that without proper due
process
um
the court has no interest in child care
any questions
any questions for Mr Collier
saying none thank you for your testimony
chair recognizes Attorney Richard head
from the judicial branch to speak to the
bill
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Richard head I'm
the government Affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch truthfully I I don't
understand this bill at all the the bill
does two things it inserts a new
paragraph Roman one in 461 A14 and
repeals RSA 461 A14
paragraph 18.
um and and I know Mr chairman you have a
copy of the statute in front of you if
you look at paragraph 18 which is the
same section so 461 A14
paragraph 18 which would be
I'm sorry
Roman 18 yes so last paragraph in that
last part in that section at least I
went through it word for word and it's
the exact same as the section that's
being added to pair F1 so as near as I
can tell this bill
repeals 18 and inserts it instead as
paragraph Roman 1.
and I don't know why and I'm not sure
what the goal was in in doing that
whether or not paragraph 18 needs
Amendment
um or changes you know that's a policy
issue but as near as I can tell the bill
goes word for word and just inserts a
new paragraph one it creates
complications I'm not sure if paragraph
18 is cited anywhere but if it is any
citation to paragraph 18 now has to be
paragraph one
um
so I can't I honestly don't know what
the what the intent of doing that was
just for reference moving something from
18 to 1 doesn't give it any more
priority
um they're all important so we just
don't understand it
anyway that I would conclude my comments
I'd be happy to answer any questions I
will agree with you counselor that what
I read 18 Roman 18 to be is the wording
of the paragraph that is inserted and to
my reading
um I see the bill changes absolutely
nothing I couldn't find anything myself
either um so if it does I got it here
and I I also have it and I I've looked
at it and I can't find it so if there is
a change it's subtle
um uh and but I couldn't find it
so it
May create I just don't know if we have
a form that cites to this paragraph if
you know what we have and it moves one
to be one a it it creates a new one
which is paragraph 18 and then shifts
everything down so or shifts one into
one a so you don't have to renumber
everything else
with the Indulgence of the committee I'm
doing a side by side at much slower
speed than I did initially to make sure
that there is absolutely nothing done it
five times very slowly and I because
every time I do it I think I'm missing
something
you know you keep this up I will go to
law school
that was a compliment by the way
foreign
they look dead on word for word so the
same punctuation appears the same
everything appears the same
thank you any any questions for attorney
head
thank you sir thank you I see no more
cards are there any more cards that want
to come up on 404.
close the hearing on House Bill 404
and open the exact session on the same
house bill 404.
again we find that the prime sponsor is
absent there is no co-sponsor there is
no one present to testify in favor of
the bill the testimony is as you heard
it paragraph one of the existing law is
simply renumbered paragraph 1A
the new paragraph one is word for word
identical to 461 A14 Roman 18 which is
repealed
I agree with the
learned Council that there this bill
changes absolutely nothing
any further comments anybody
chair will entertain a motion
thank you
thank you Mr chairman I'll move uh itl
on House Bill 404. chair the chairman
owes representative D Simone a second
would you like to second
representative D Simone
any further discussion on House Bill 404
seeing no further discussion
I call the question on House Bill 404
the motion is in expedient to legislate
moved by representative long seconded by
representative D Simone
would the clerk please call the roll if
you wish to itl the book The the bill it
is an i or yes if you don't like itl it
is a no or an A
chairman Pearson
I
representative long yes
representative DeSimone yes
representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes
representative Panic is absent
representative Seidel yes representative
Grossman is absent representative
Levesque
representative Petrino will be voting
yes representative Perez
yes representative Greg yes
representative Moulton yes
representative Raymond yes the itl
passes 14-0 with two in not in the
tenants
any objection to this going on consent
seeing hearing none the paper for the
committee report will be given to
representative long who will get it back
to me before the close of business today
this ends the executive session on House
Bill 404 before we go off to a long
lunch
a couple of business items for the
committee
I've been asked to read
house committee temporary replacement
policy we will be having next week a a
morning of executing some bills
I'll send you all an email ahead of the
calendar so if you are not going to be
here or you're going to want to spend
time elsewhere listen to this any House
member unable to participate in a
scheduled policy committee meeting may
be replaced on a temporary basis using
the following protocol
how to notify of your absence
contact your chair or designee
of the chair or your ranking member
Democrats to let that person know you
cannot participate in an upcoming
executive session and do that as soon as
possible your chair or ranking member
will then determine if a replacement is
necessary not all meetings necessitate a
replacement if we plan on not executing
if it looks like the bills are
controversial enough that we will not
exec immediately
you don't have to worry but if we are
going to exec or it looks like we're
going to exec and that's not always easy
to determine you'll want to contact us
if it has been determined that a
placement is necessary
this person will notify your respective
caucus office either the house
Republican office or house Democratic
office so that the staff there may begin
the process of identifying a member to
replace you for the day on your
committee
the caucus office then submits a written
request to the speaker's office who
approves the request and notifies the
proper entities to make sure that the
replacement is on file with officers who
manage the meetings and keep the records
deadline
with house committees requiring an
in-person attendance by legislators
staff must be given the appropriate time
to identify a replacement which may be
one of many vacancies they're trying to
fill on any given day therefore all
requests for temporary Replacements must
be received by the house Republican or
Democratic offices no later than 4 pm on
the day prior to the meeting and by the
way if you have to
Notify myself or vice chairman long you
got to do it before then because then
we've got to make the call by 4 pm is a
Committee Member it is extremely
important to notify your chair or
ranking member as soon as possible don't
wait for the deadline because your
caucus office will still need to
identify a replacement contact the
speaker's office and notify the proper
entities which takes time
when can I be replaced most Replacements
happen when executive sessions are
expected
or properly noticed in the house
calendar to ensure each party's vote
counts are not affected by absences keep
an eye out for executive session notices
in the calendar and I will try to let
you know ahead of that time and stay in
contact with your chair or ranking
member to determine if votes may be
taken on any given meeting day you
cannot be replaced
due to conflicts with other business in
the state house or the lob if you're in
the building you cannot be replaced no
matter what else you're doing for
example
you cannot be replaced in your Committee
in order to introduce a bill in another
committee or attend another hearing or
in the house or Senate however you can
be replaced if you serve on two
committees that happen to have
conflicting executive sessions scheduled
can you be replaced for partial day no
if you seek to be replaced you are
replaced for the day
how long is the replacement good for
members are typically replaced one day
at a time however if you expect to be an
ex in an extended absence you're having
surgery you know you'll be out for a
couple weeks your caucus office can
indicate the period of an extended
absence or replacement if necessary can
I request to replace myself with someone
of my own choosing no only the
Republican or Democratic leader can
request that a member be temporarily
replaced
please work with your caucus office to
determine the best way to handle your
replacement any questions on the
replacement policy
representative side down I knew that
before you did that
um on the 24 hour or 4 pm the day before
if it's the holiday on Monday where we
meet Tuesday morning would it have to be
the Friday previous or is it still that
Monday
I don't know
that's a good question you want their
home phone numbers
actually that did come up once and I did
call uh one of the members of in my case
the Republican office on his cell phone
and I didn't know what he said after he
hung up but he was very polite while I
was he was on the phone with me
so I don't know yeah do you see that
coming up
okay it's in in general hypothetical
okay that's a good thing to ask
any other questions
um sure thank you Mr chairman
um I
well I want to apologize for being late
however every Tuesday there's a chair
and vice chair meeting and
um
Mr chairman and I have decided that
we're going to take turns
um he stayed last one I stayed this one
so and representative DeSimone it would
also be late because she's a vice chair
on another committee uh so you know just
to let you know that on Tuesdays from 9
15 to 9 45 I believe
so one of us will be late and that's the
reason why we call them the designated
Survivor okay
yes representative
thank you I just want the people in the
audience to understand that we mean
absolutely no disrespect we understand
that the uh bills will be called when
they're called and if we come in late
we mean no disrespect at all your
testimony is very important to all of us
let me give you a
uh up to the minute heads up on House
Bill 120 it has been noticed in the
calendar for executive session at three
o'clock this afternoon and I cannot
execute any earlier
what we have planned this is lots of
people bipartisan bicameral
even by branches of government is that
Senate bill one on the sununu center
replacement
has passed this the whole Senate
unanimously has come over here it has
bypassed this committee
and is going directly to
house finance
they will deal with it I believe
tomorrow
and it will go to the floor of the house
as soon as possible
I've been asked to entertain a motion to
retain
which means we hold on to it
uh 120. this afternoon so any of you who
who are here I do need a quorum so don't
all leave
we will retain the bill which may mean
if we really need it for some reason if
something goes wrong in the process
we'll have it in our pocket to deal with
if everything goes right and is signed
into law the hope is by the end of
February at the latest
then we will just simply take this up at
a later date and agree to kill it so
that's the that's the plan this takes
place from three o'clock oh oh to three
o'clock
30 seconds this afternoon
all right with that we will break for
lunch and come back at 1 15. you get a
nice long lunch this time
for Bill 411 that we're going to be
hearing in a few minutes please make
sure they come down keep those cards and
letters coming
I just have one which could mean I've
lost several others
yours yep okay good fine
well I should
nope this is for 6 35.
yeah he's good thank you that's right
didn't look I had a meeting over the
Lynn shower
open the hearing on House Bill 411 the
chair calls representative testerman the
sponsor of the bill
saying that representative testerman is
absent
Vice chairman long
thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman I'd
like to introduce House Bill
411--f-n relative to the mediation of
cases involving children
thank you representative
you have the bill before you it is very
very small it repeals RSA
461 for
I mean a seven
and instead we read
the court May recommend mediation and
give parents referrals of certified
mediators but the court shall not order
mediation that's what this bill seeks to
do simply is to take away ordered
mediation chair recognizes Attorney
Richard head from the judicial branch to
speak
about the bill
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the committee my name is Richard head
I'm the government Affairs coordinator
for the judicial branch
um with this bill I do sort of
understand I think the the idea that is
behind it um the bill itself is very
short the section though it seeks to
repeal and replace is actually a fairly
long and detailed and sort of talks
about mediation in under 461 a
um
I did want to talk about our mediation
program why it is it gets issued as an
order and what some of the consequences
would be of not allowing these to be
issued by by an order first just in
terms of the concept of mediation
whether it's ordered or whether it is
simply
created by the parties themselves not
through an order
the mediation itself is a a process that
does not require the parties to reach
agreement it is an opportunity to reach
agreement and it's an opportunity to
reach agreement on some or all of the
issues that may be coming before the the
court in their particular case
the court and and
uh the judges and the staff we do
strongly encourage parties to mediate we
have as you've heard me say and you'll
continue to hear me say in extremely
busy system and the more the parties are
able to reach agreement the more issues
they can resolve on their own the fewer
that are in before a judge
in the and when you're in front of a
judge it is going to be adversarial
um it is the nature of the proceeding so
the the goal is wherever possible and
whenever possible to have the parties
reach agreement and if they are unable
to do so on their own they do it with
the help of a mediator
so why is it that we order mediation
which in and of itself is not a process
that requires the parties to reach
agreement it seems a little almost
contradictory in the in the sense of
well when you get there you don't have
to actually reach agreement but you're
being ordered to go there
and there are some very practical
reasons associated with that at some
level one is
um payment so if the parties are free to
go out and select their own mediator
um and and and pay their whatever it is
they're going to charge the mediator can
charge whatever they want to charge and
the court is not going to help fund that
even order is issued under this
statutory provision the rule kicks in
regarding how much the mediator is going
to be paid and the mediator is going to
be paid for 300 for up to four sessions
plus an hour of and for at one hour
sessions plus one hour of administration
time
that is just sort of baked into the fee
so unlike some who might charge 300 an
hour 300 for a half day whatever it may
be the fee is set by rule if it's issued
as an order
if the parties are Indigent and unable
to pay again if it's issued as an order
the Court's arbitration and mediation
fund will pay for that
but it still has to be issued as an
order we're not going to pay the private
mediator 300 an hour we're going to pay
the mediator it's on the list under the
court schedule the 300
for four hours plus one hour of
administration time so there is sort of
a practical reason we do an order
sometimes the parties will come to the
court and say we want to mediate great
I'm going to issue an order of demediate
because then they get into the system
they get into that process that without
the order they're simply not going to be
eligible for it so there is sort of a
very uh practical reason why we do this
as as an order
um in terms of the mediation process
itself we do sort of evaluate whether or
not it's working how it's working what
the feedback is and the parties the
participants in a in a mediation are
asked to complete a survey it's
completely voluntary they choose to
great if they choose not to
um then that's their decision so we have
like survey results from 2021
um I think it's 2021 I might be wrong
about that we had 127 people participate
in the survey
and it was a pretty even split in terms
of how they resolved about half of them
settled all the issues about 22 percent
settled some of the issues and about 23
percent subtle no issues so you get a
mix within the people
of of who's providing feedback so the
question uh on the survey did the
mediator explain the process clearly 98
said yes I was treated fairly and with
respect 98 percent and said yes the
mediator was impartial and treated all
parties equally 95 percent said yes
mediator helped us explore options 91
percent said yes
and then probably the most important I
would use mediation again if needed in
this or any other case 91 said yes it is
a a at least the feedback we receive is
very positive very favorably obviously
you know
oh
they get positive feedback
it is a beneficial process because it
does resolve issues it brings people
together in front of a professional
mediator who then is able to help people
identify the issues see if there's areas
of agreement see if their areas where
simply you cannot agree and narrow
potentially or eliminate the issues that
are going to be brought before a judge
in a adversarial proceeding with
Witnesses with testimony whatever it may
be
so the the
the
the bill
simply eliminates all of that and says
parties use the free market decide
whether or not you're going to be
mediating and you lose an awful lot by
doing that
um
so
we do not support the bill is written
because we really do need to have all of
the tools available to us to be able to
try to resolve issues and bring parties
to agreement as opposed to
the adversarial process that that you
see in a courtroom with that I'll
conclude my comments I'd be happy to
answer any questions
attorney had a Euro would you guess
along with me that perhaps the reason
for this bill is that there may be
circumstances where it would be a bad
idea to
order mediation and with that in mind
are you familiar with 461 a 7 Roman 5
which reads the court shall not order
mediation if there's a finding of
domestic violence that is to say the
existing law takes into account reasons
why this shouldn't happen so a blanket
statement is overreach
um so thank you for the question I think
the answer is yes
um and
the
it is extremely important and difficult
because there's some that are we know
there's been a DV petition filed
um
then there you get into some that are
more difficult the judge may not have
affirmatively heard from a party that
that that's an issue there's
a goal to make sure that if there's an
to give everyone the opportunity to do
that it's also through the mediation
process and have the mediator and the
mediators are knowledgeable about
whether or not parties should be in
mediation or if there's an undisclosed
domestic violence issue or some other
issue that
if brought together create a greater
risk and creates more problems whether
you know that aspect of it can be done
better or worse this build is simply
does not address that and creates more
problems because it takes the court out
of the out of the equation entirely
any further questions
representative D Simone thank you Mr
chairman
and thank you for taking my question
I'm not really sure where this bill is
headed but when I read
um
RSA 461 A7 and if I go to Roman 4 it
gives a list of reasons uh the court may
choose not to order mediation that
include but are not limited to
and I I can't imagine
inserting anything else than this in
this laundry list of undue hardship
an agreement between the parties which
would mean there's no need for mediation
uh allegations of abuse alcoholism
drug abuse
psychological or emotional abuse
uh
available suitable mediators so
wouldn't this cover the gamut in your
opinion so thank you for the question I
think so if if we thought there should
be other reasons one there's nothing
stopping us from saying it's not on the
list but for whatever reason these
parties in front of us should not be
together in a room in a mediation the
the list is not limited to
um so absolutely so I'm to answer your
question no I'm unaware of any other
specific circumstances where it would be
helpful to include in the list and the
list is uh is sufficiently brought to
allow us to go outside of it if there
are instances where
parties have been ordered into mediation
where they shouldn't have been
we need to hear about those instances
and as to what happened and why so that
we can learn from them
but that doesn't mean that we should as
a blanket rule eliminate the court from
being involved in ordering mediation I
think that's a just a different
step that that is really a not even just
an overreach but is ultimately harmful
to the process
thank you
representative Bickford thank you Mr
chairman
what I didn't notice in here uh the
statue
is anything about those that may have
agreed upon all their points some people
do I know
uh they just say well we just want a
park company and we've already made our
agreement how we're going to split up
things do they need to go through the
mediation they don't so we do so thank
you for the question the there are a
significant
percentage of cases
by significant truth I I'll say 20 in
the 20 some odd percent and I might be
completely wrong about that so don't
hold on don't write it down okay just
don't write that one down but it it it's
not it's a substantial number who
are going through this process are able
to reach full agreements and file
agreements and they have almost no court
interaction
well if I may follow through but I don't
see it in the statute that says they
would be excused from
um mediation and that was my point I
guess do we need anything like that so
should I say
um
I'm not going to find it under they
don't they do not I've only got seven in
front of me uh I don't know if there's
something before that or not if if the
parties have reached agreement so the
other aspect of this is so at uh at the
first session they are there's a there's
a Corp there's somebody in the court
system that's assigned to their case and
we'll meet with them and if they're
reaching an agreement on their own
without the need for a mediator
they are not going to be forced into
into a mediation where they've already
resolved all the problems sometimes the
parties are able to reach agreement they
just don't know how to sort of document
it so they go okay we'll either work
with the court staff person and sort of
then document it or maybe they need to
use the mediator to sort of finalize the
individual terms but no parties are able
to and do reach agreement without going
through a court-ordered mediation
okay thank you representative DeSimone I
think you had a point of information
um I did find a point of information to
your question
um representative Bickford it does
discuss
um the court shall not order mediation
if there is a finding of domestic
violence as defined in 173 B colon 1
unless all parties agreed to mediation
but that's under that
if I made the the that's under the
domestic violence part I was speaking
broadly about not people necessarily
coming under that umbrella thank you
yeah thank you
in going to the the uh representative
desimone's point in the list it's not
limited to this list so if the parties
come to the judge and say we've got
everything reached you know we're done
we're not gonna We're Not Gonna force
him into a process that they don't need
um and in that circumstance we just we
do though if there are issues we do
pretty strongly encourage people into
mediation
thank you
further questions anyone
representative Simoni what was the
number 173
7.
foreign
thank you
with the concurrence I almost said
complicity concurrence
of the ranking member I closed the
hearing on
this bill
and open the exact section session on
the same
any discussion
once again the sponsor
is not here nor is there any co-sponsor
who could answer any questions there has
been no positive testimony on this
and as we heard section
RSA 461 A7 opened up we understood that
there are reasons where the court would
not order this and I think we understand
that a domestic violence situation is
well within that boundary we also saw
that there's numbers of reasons why the
court might choose not to
we also knew that uh know that if both
parties are Indigent I'm quoting the law
then the mediator should be paid to set
free
it seems that any to my mind possible
reason why we should in a blanket way
strike the Court's duty to get mediation
going on have been answered in the law
already
and that there's nothing to be gained by
this bill and there's quite a bit that
could be lost that's just my two cents
worth anyone else
chair will entertain a
motion
from representative
are you making a motion I'm not making
motion I wanted to make a comment I'll
just entertain your comment excellent
thank you Mr chairman
um
I have concerns that we would be tying
the Court's hands with this bill as
opposed to it seems like the court has
adequate discretion at this point with
the current law so so I'm essentially
echoing what you were saying before but
I just wanted to let you know I'm in
agreement
thank you
you can be my echo anytime
anyone else
now the chair will entertain emotion
representative
Levesque
I move itl
representative Levesque
moves itl
I can second that
I heard you wonderfully
thank you representative perezen I was
to say to the committee that um I teased
attempted to tease the good
representative this morning in a way
that was not
the best way to do it and I apologized
to her and I wish to apologize to the
committee
the fact is I don't hear well in any
language my ears are not good so thank
you representative for your graciousness
and your second
any further discussion
the motion before us is on House Bill
411 FN
the motion is in expedient to legislate
move by representative Levesque and
seconded by representative Perez and the
assistant clerk please call the roll
chairman Pearson
yes
Vice chairman long yes
representative DeSimone yes
representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson
yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes
representative pennant is not in today
representative Seidel yes
representative Grossman
not here sorry
representative Levesque yes
Representative Patrick know is not in
representative Perez
yes
representative Greg yes representative
Moulton yes representative Raymond yes
so that's going to be it should be 13 to
0.
the itl would pass
that's right 13 to 0 and the objection
to consent
and representative Levesque before close
of business today if you could write out
the Mr chairman of zibin and Eve written
testimony come in on these bills no
okay because I know my email got messed
up and I was wondering if I was missing
something I didn't see any
thank you
this close is the exact session on House
Bill 411 F and we will resume at two
o'clock for
House Bill 635
uh I think is that right oh good
which will repeal parenting plans and
the contents of parenting plans so
you got 20 minutes
um
I think
chairman Bob
um I I know that we share this room with
you have we both stayed our welcome and
you've got your people coming in
using the RSA
thank you well we'll clean up the damage
and you'll have it in good shape for
tomorrow
okay
foreign
brother I hate to break it up but it's
two o'clock
and we will now hear House Bill 635 uh
the part of Testament is played by law
okay and the chair College
representative testerman to present his
bill he is the prime and sole sponsor of
House Bill 635 and we will the chair
recognizes representative long
thank you Mr chairman
I'd like to introduce House Bill 635 FN
relative to court ordered counseling and
parenting plans
thank you very much any of you who
either have
hard copy book or have it online this is
RSA 461 A4 which is all about parenting
plans and the content of parenting plans
and so on and I see
um
the bill is to eliminate all of this the
chair recognizes Mr Randall Collier to
come up and
speak about the bill
thank you chair and committee members
for allowing me to speak about this bill
I
agree there should be
um
the whole point of parenting plans and
children's uh best interests once again
the Supreme Court has ruled that um
Troxel versus gavel in 2000 that um the
courts don't have any uh interest in
in family as Equity is is property and
finances and not actual people
um
I'm sorry clarify that I'm trying to get
my mind around you're saying that the
court would that be the U.S Supreme
Court the family court the family court
of New Hampshire correct or any family
court it's not a criminal court right
right so they to the Supreme Court the
U.S Supreme Courts ruled that the family
courts don't have any ground or interest
in the family issues um
because for the child's best interest
it's not to have a third party arbiter
speaking on behalf of the kid especially
when the judge doesn't know either party
would you give the Supreme Court
citation
you did a minute ago and it went a
little yeah you know I don't hear well
uh Supreme Court Troxell versus
Granville 530 U.S 57 in year 2000 where
the Supreme Court said that uh family
courts
um
studies
I'm sorry that was still too fast I
didn't get I got true so spell the names
the the case is Troxel versus Granville
t-r-o-x-e-l proxel first Granville
g-r-a-n-v-i-l-l-e uh and the the case
number is 530 U.S 57 in the year 2000.
thank you sir okay uh stating that it's
a constitutional constitutional right
for parents um to direct the upbringing
and not have a third party Arbiter
um Furthermore with parenting plans in
regards to uh court court ordered
counseling
um
I hate to use this as my case because
it's an ongoing thing
um
the the judge or the family court
doesn't have
um
[Music]
with the evidence submitted such as like
psychological records and psychiatric
records
um
my judge decided to contradict both
medical records and then give me
counseling for 25 different hypothetical
orders
um the very first reason the judge gave
me for supervised visits and this was 12
years ago
um was so my son doesn't lose memory of
his good relationship with his father
that was the number one reason I got
supervised visits through the family
court in New Hampshire
not only that the judge said that I was
confused which which is kind of weird
because he's practicing medicine without
a medical license and they didn't really
understand that
um so anyway
um yeah I agree that it should be
appealed uh or repealed
um
and there there is no best interest of
the kid when there's title 40 incentives
uh through the federal government to
give the judge matching funds every time
he grants child support so there's no
actual incentive for the judge to
actually follow due process so
um
and I have all the evidence any
questions
representative Nelson I'm I'm just a
little confused because
um I'm I pulled up the statute and it's
talking about parenting plans like in
terms of holidays and birthdays and
schedules and transportation and
exchange of the child so I'm confused
about how your testimony is pertaining
to that
well when the judge grants the parenting
plan right
it's supposed to be in the best instance
of a child and it's not supposed to be a
party uh
granted uh equally not all for one
parent right
um that's actually not what happens in
New Hampshire if you want to see the
evidence so
um
there is no best interest from a judge
granting for a child that he doesn't
know right if he gets matching funds
through the government to run his
courtroom
he's not looking out for the best
interest of the kid he's he's running a
business so the parenting plan
should be mediated between both parties
only and not anybody else Supreme Court
already ruled on that so
but it says an act relative to court
ordered Counseling in parenting plans so
if the judge contradicts the psyche vows
and then practices medicine with a
medical license that needs to be
addressed first before we try and change
any rules
thank you
any other questions Jim
down here
representative Bickford thank you Mr
chairman
um well I I think
Society has been using uh the system of
of a judge or so since uh King Solomon
um now Troxel I don't know if you're
aware was a grandparent rights issue and
not between two parents well there was
two parents involved but one died
and the case came out of Washington it's
what gave us a parental why we didn't
give grandparents similar rights as
parents
so I don't think that's really the right
case to cite for this okay thank you
any further questions
representative Moulton thank you Mr
chairman so
in all of the evidence that you
presented I I was a little confused on
if you support
this bill as written or not
I support repealing the parenting plan
bill
in the fourth because there's other
between the 461 A6 A7 uh and I believe
A2 there's a lot of discrepancies that
need to be addressed that go along with
the parenting plan that I found uh very
conflicting information
um that's why I submitted it to
other parties follow-up follow-up
I guess I'm not sure that
why you would
suggests that
um repealing parenting plans in general
would be the solution to there being
issues with just one parenting plan
there has to be an equally
agreed upon parenting plan right so the
judges can't order a parenting plan
without actual due process and having
your rights actually taken away by a
proper court so until that happens which
it never does because they always give
protective orders in Family Court
without actual proper criminal
prosecution
so when they do that and they Implement
a parenting plan
it's always in the best interest of
usually the mother if you go by
statistically it's like over 90 I don't
have the exact number
um
and we have to we have to figure out why
that is and and why the family court is
is is making these rules
for parents when they're directly
contradicting the evidence to submitted
so that's I mean we have to get to the
bottom of it before we fix other things
so if you're just fixing small things
you still have have a bigger problem
that they're still not following law and
doing what they're doing like a judge
can't say that you're confused if your
eval says you're not right so
when they Implement plans that are
actually directly contradicting the
evidence
we have to have a bigger a bigger
discussion of what's really going on in
these family courts
so then are you suggesting that if there
was no
legal parenting plan that the court
followed that they would just Implement
what you and your ex decided is that
what is that what you they would have to
implement something right so first of
all they have to have first of all they
have to have legal jurisdiction right so
if you're not wanted for a crime they
can't come they can't make orders over
you they can't just arbitrarily say well
your son has your last name but
you're not going to get to see him for
12 years right which happened in my case
so they have to they have to be able to
run the program legally first of all
they have to have jurisdiction over you
so
If the parents can't communicate there
has to be a way to the community to
communicate for a plan right and that's
why we're here
um
it's just not in the best interest of
the child to have a judge do it
right because he's getting Financial
funds to run his courtroom
so when they do that it's a conflict of
interest so they're never going to look
out for the best interest of the kid
when they're doing a parenting plan
so in mine they said Mr Collier will
know exactly what's expected of him
right well why is anything expected of
me if there's no evidence of wrongdoing
should be 50 50.
so we have to fix a problem ahead of the
small
statues and statues are really only
followed and agreed upon if they're
agreed upon by both parties then they're
legal but it's not an actual ultimate
law supreme law in its Constitution
so a lot of these statues are are
unconstitutional
so before we start writing these we need
to figure out why they're
unconstitutional and why they're being
written the way they are
you have a follow-up
anybody else
all right thank you so much thank you
and the chair recognizes
Matthew Hayes
attorney Matthew Hayes
bcss Bureau of children
anybody what
I should have known that thank you I got
the HHS part I took six years to learn
that one
my apologies with chairman uh I should
I'll write it out next time just to make
sure probably for about six months and
then I think I'll be good okay no
problem thank you
uh thank you uh my name is attorney
Matthew Hayes from Bureau chocolate oh
I turned it on this time okay now we're
even
now this time I need to make sure I get
it towards my uh where I'm talking
um very quickly I just want to thank you
for letting me to uh speak on behalf of
the Bureau of Child Support
um sort of a housekeeping matters how I
would refer to it in court
um it was requested that the bureau
provide a fiscal note and most recently
when we reviewed the docket on The
house's website it said that it was
still outstanding we submitted a fiscal
note
uh and I believe January 13th um I know
that the lva is is working hard I'm sure
they're super busy
um but I just want to make sure that the
committee if they didn't already have it
wanted to know our fiscal position was
that this bill uh as a policy decision
were neutral but there's no fiscal
impact that we were able to determine
for our program so I just want to make
sure the committee had that information
no fiscal impact thank you
happy to take questions but I I
generally I on this type of Bill we
don't deal with parenting plan so I
really didn't add anything other than
really no fiscal impact I just didn't
want it to look like that we didn't
respond
representative Moulton
thank you Mr chairman um I know he said
you weren't going to take any questions
but I thought
I thought that the child support section
is under the parenting plan is it not or
is that a separate section
uh no I'm sorry if I misspoke I'm happy
to take questions from the committee
already
um I just uh
my program deals with enforcing and
establishmenting child support orders
um were were resources are confined
towards that end and we don't deal with
parenting plans so
um
when it's written in the the divorce
papers
doesn't the child support fall under the
parenting plan uh the child support
would be issued in the uniform support
order which is a separate uh form a
court form I say okay I'd be happy to
provide a blank copy to the
representative if you wish no it's okay
I just I just wasn't sure if this spill
would repeal that so okay that's all
child support's not in here
but if it was part of the parenting plan
then it would end up incidentally
repealed in the event it was in the
parenting plan if it's a separate issue
then it's not going to be
yeah that's why I was just asking a
question if it was or not well I think
child support plans are somewhere else
in here uh
but to eliminate something that isn't
there
wouldn't preclude it coming in later
under another heading
I got the answer because it's it's not
under the parenting plan so so it would
not be repealed I'm glad we had this
conversation
anybody else
thank you so much counselor and we now
call on Attorney Richard head from the
judicial brands
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Richard head I
am the government Affairs coordinator
for the judicial branch
we do not support this this bill which
would repeal the section dealing with
parenting plans I don't know if you
remember but when judge Gardner came and
spoke at it at the at the introductory
session he identified our parenting
plans as one of the most effective tools
that we have in parenting cases
after that presentation I did forward a
copy of our parenting plan form to the
committee I'm happy if anyone wants
another copy to resend it it is
a well laid out form that follows a
statutory provisions and it is it
provides a step-by-step basis for
parties to go through and identify
really all of the parenting issues in in
fairly simple ways but in great detail
parenting issues that the parties need
to resolve and try to resolve before
coming before a judge and the goal of
the parenting plan is for the parties to
reach agreement on the content of that
parenting plan not to have a parenting
plan imposed upon them and the and and
it takes the parties through
the Essential Elements of what needs to
be in a parenting plan who has
decision-making responsibility what are
the residential responsibilities and and
schedules holiday and birthday planning
three-day weekends vacation schedules
supervised Vision uh parenting time if
applicable other parental
responsibilities and and just lays it
out in fairly simple terms but requires
the parties to think about it and
hopefully come to resolution or if they
can't come to resolution on all of them
they come to resolution on a large
number of them
so a couple things with regard to the
bill which would eliminate the statutory
provision on parenting Plans by the way
there are a lot of references to that
section throughout the statutes
that are now left hanging If This Were
to be repealed
it's unclear as to as from our
perspective as to why it is that this
this bill would would come forward where
one of the essential things that has to
be resolved in a parenting case is
parenting issues and if we take away
that essential tool
sort of how do we come to those to those
resolutions and I appreciate the thought
of you know judges why are Judges making
these decisions judges are not making
these decisions if they don't need to
um if there is no agreement or if the
agreement is ultimately not in the best
interest of the children
the judge gets involved but the judges
are not looking to get involved they're
looking for the parties to reach
agreement looking for something that
works and that is most likely going to
happen when the parties develop it
themselves so
in in summary we do not support the bill
we find that parenting plan process is
is extremely effective uh and is an
essential Tool uh for the courts to have
and taking that away will have
significant ramifications in in these
types of cases and with that I'll
conclude my comments but I would be
happy to answer any questions
representative Moulton
thank you Mr chairman
um what would you anticipate would be
the outcome in the event that apparent
there was no parenting plan whatsoever
um so thank you for the question I
suspect we would Implement something
through a rule
um and we would have to
um because I'm not quite sure what else
we would do
um it is the thing that we're trying to
resolve
you would like a follow-up wouldn't you
I sure would you may have a one thank
you
how would you so
I mean I just I foresee a lot of issues
with this so I see uh more than a lot of
it so like if you
how would you hold someone in contempt
like how would you know that you've met
all of the different you know that you
fully resolved how like to parent
between these two individuals that are
you know as a practical matter I I just
I have to assume without knowing that
um as a branch we would need to develop
a very essentially a parallel process
through rulemaking and through a Court
rule and through a court I mean we have
a form we would probably just implement
the form through rules but
I don't get it I don't get why the
statute would would come out and it
creates just sort of logistical problems
within the statutory framework of
everything we have as a form that
references the section needs the work
that would go into change you know
fixing the statutory and Rule and form
references
for
what we do not understand to be the
reason is is a lot of work that would
take a great deal of resources for and
and then to create a essentially a new
process
um
is is just at a time when the court does
not have sufficient resources
um it is unclear as to why we would be
doing that
anyone else
representative Raymond
thank you Mr chairman um and thank you
attorney ahead for taking my question my
question is
um kind of a more Global question than
just New Hampshire so we have this great
parenting plan Forum which is frankly in
my opinion a model for other states
um but pretty much every state has their
own and there's a federal law the
uniform oh uniform custody
chairman Pearson knows it the uniform I
can read child uniform child custody
jurisdiction and Enforcement Act yes so
I guess my question is would we run a
foul of those Federal requirements
should we get rid of our parenting plan
um
it's a good question that on off the off
the cuff I'm going to be reluctant to
answer well it would be easier if I said
it right the first no no that's fine I
get what you're saying and I and I know
what you're saying I just wouldn't been
able to come up with the words
um and I'm so I'm just reluctant to just
to answer that some type and I didn't
specifically in preparation for today so
I think that through okay okay um sorry
I apologize nope that's all right thank
you my question is if all this went away
there's no requirement
for a parenting plan to be worked out by
the parents
and if all this went away wouldn't it be
the case then that we have no mandated
procedures if one parent relocates and
takes the child or children that we have
no mandated holiday birthday vacation
planning that we have no mandated legal
residents for a child for attending
school were all this to go away so my
question is would this not mean
what happens in these and other issues
is by which parent is the stronger and
can get away with it
if there is no mandated
having them work a plan out I think what
it would so thank you for the question
it
I think that yes I think at some level
every single time there is
any disagreement which is true anyway
but if we don't have a parenting plan in
order to fall back on
every they're just continuously making
it up without any without an underlying
order document template to say this is
what this is what we're falling back on
this is the default which is the
parenting plan you want to deviate from
the parenting plan come back to the
court and and tell us why and tell us
how it how you know why that is but at
the end of the day the parenting plan
will re will be the thing that resolves
dispute
and and and and the goal is to try to
limit ongoing future disputes and and to
have this outline through the plan
so is it the case that absent a
parenting plan it would either be
the tougher stronger richer parent would
rule it because of force or they would
be constant going back to the court
constant documents constant expense
I think the the latter one uh and
um and in some level to the extent
relative to the first if if there is a
disparity financially that party can use
that in a way to the detriment or the
other for the pure sake of of doing it
to the detriment of the other
thank you any further questions
representative Vice chairman long
thank you Mr chairman uh so Mr head the
the uh part of this chapter they're
looking to repeal uh it also states that
uh
uh neither parent shall be described as
Heaven's child reside primary
or Primary Residential responsibility or
custody
or Primary Residential parents so in
your opinion would we revert revert back
to judges
giving
a parent the residential the primary
care parent or the
Primary Residential period which gave us
all these issues that brought us to this
so thank you for the question I think
probably at least in the short term we
would sort of stick with what we're used
to but I don't know how it would start
to change over time
um and and where it flows back into and
and you know you lose the structure and
you might start to lose the the
structure within the decision making
that's why I do think ultimately If This
Were to pass
um there would be a another structure
that we would just have to create
separately
because that structure is is sort of
essential okay thank you
representative D Simone
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
attorney head for taking my question
um isn't it true that wherever there is
a an area that could be in conflict in
this parenting plan that I just read it
gives the opportunity to the parents to
resolve any issue and if they cannot
that is where the court intervenes
um so thank you yes that is absolutely
right and that is
absolutely what we want
um and and so that is the goal thank you
anyone else
saying no one thank you so much thank
you any pink card on House Bill 635 that
has not found its way up here
seeing none I will close the hearing on
House Bill 635. Let's actually want to
go to exec and I now open the executive
session on House Bill 635 and let's have
any discussion we might want to have
before we entertain a motion
representative
Raymond uh thank you Mr chairman
um I think the theme today has been
um a general feeling of concern on the
part of some of these bills about how
long
um the process is taking in Family Court
um you know and and allowing families to
to proceed potentially uh more
efficiently through the system and I
think that's a laudable goal I think
that
um the court could use something to
assist it with that I just don't think
that these bills on this one in
particular is the mechanism by which we
fix or improve the system that we have
I said earlier I think that the New
Hampshire parenting plan form is a model
having worked in New York and I'm
familiar with Massachusetts
custody it's much better than those two
other states I can't speak for all
states but ours is so much more user
friendly and easy to understand
so my my opinion on this one is that
unfortunately once again I don't think
it should move forward as written
thank you so much anyone else
representative Moulton thank you Mr
chairman uh I have a lot of concerns
about this bill I think it's unsafe if
we take away a parenting plan we have
nothing to put it in place the parenting
plan is designed for
for protecting the kids
um
I think the only way to you're right
that that we have problems with with
bottlenecking in the courts but the only
way through that is to get more judges
we you know we need
deregulating isn't going to solve it
it's going to cause more problems in the
long run which is going to make more
people have to go back to court for
different issues because they didn't
have it in writing to begin with and
we're creating more problems than we
would be solving
thank you anyone else
representative log thank you Mr chairman
I I um I mean I think I know the intent
of this I mean after listening to Mr
Collier I I empathize with him I I get
it uh why is he
why was it so long for him to get to
visit his child that I don't understand
and I get frustrated over that
um I and I see where this would just get
rid of that however it'd be just like um
when I eat a cupcake with my diabetes it
goes Skyrocket so I'm going to put in a
bill to get rid of cupcakes
you know it affects me and
you know to get to the detail of the
problem would be better I'd be more open
to that to see if we can get a fix than
just throw something blanket like this
across where it's going to create other
issues
um so yeah I'll be uh
in opposition
I would put in a bill to eliminate
diabetes but that's just me
representative Bickford
thank you Mr chairman
um this is important to me because it
was 20 years ago that I filed this
for parenting plants it hadn't been
heard of before New Hampshire all right
something I picked up and saw in the
state of Washington and brought it
forward
when I when I presented I was pretty
much laughed out of the
out of the building
and uh nobody was in favor of it at that
time so but there was an attorney in the
audience that heard me speak to it and
his name was John Cameron he had come
into family law left chemical
engineering to do that after his divorce
and uh we created another bill I believe
was an amendment that created the family
law task force which I highly recommend
doing again
um and we looked at all facets and we
rewrote the family law statutes
uh so and we took children out of the
marriage path put it into its own place
because not everybody that's married has
children
um
and and
so we came back in 2005 and we got it
passed and I see there's been a that
section that you uh representative long
spoke to uh is very important to father
because
um
the old system was uh visitation
and people viewed that as losing their
parental rights
um they want a parent they were
Revisited to the children and we felt
that the language needed to uh to change
as because we didn't have
parental rights and responsibilities
it was
custody or ownership
and visitors and uh this is one of the
biggest things we did so I'd be
privileged to uh
do the itl
you anticipated my request
all we need is
emotion
for emotion or any more sharing
discussing
representative Bickford for a motion
please ah thank you Mr chairman I'd uh
like to move itl on uh
house bills 6 35. and
representative Greg would like to Second
it
yeah you may second it and you turn your
microphone on and seconded as well I'll
second it again
with the microphone this time your
microphone is on and you'd like to
Second this wouldn't you I thought so
okay good any further discussion before
we uh
have the roll called saying hearing none
thank you
the motion before us is itl on House
Bill 635 FN
moved by representative Bickford
enthusiastically seconded by
representative Greg thank you
yeah
and when the clerk's ready please call
the roll
chairman Pearson yes
Vice chairman long yes representative
representative DeSimone yes
representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic is not here
representative Seidel
yes representative Grossman is not here
representative Levesque
yes representative petrigno is not here
uh representative Perez yes
representative gray yes Greg I'm sorry
representative Moulton yes
representative Raymond yes
that would be 14 yes zero no's and three
not here no it's 13. there's always 13.
I wrote 13. did you vote twice
I don't know why I wrote 13 I said 14.
don't ask me and um
that's reminding me no no I appreciate
that any objection to consenting hearing
none it's on consent and uh if you know
where the papers are for representative
Bickford to fill out the committee
report they're in the stash here
somewhere and also have we given you one
for your we didn't it's not personal we
just forgot okay
laughs
okay
one two
and this uh closes the
exact session on House Bill 635 and I
hope you'll all stay around have some
fun with chatting with each other
because I have to wait till three
o'clock for a 30-second
um
exact session on House Bill 120. so
thank you
foreign
[Music]
question of the committee for a minute
please
just want to let you know what we're
going to be doing on February
7th a week from today
we'll be having an executive session at
9 30 in the morning and if you've got a
pen and pencil ready paper ready or
your phone
um I'll give you the numbers of the
bills we will be exacting
good night
next Tuesday 9 30 a.m exec session 218
rules and transcripts in Family Court
representative Bernardi 108
confidentiality of reports
representative Spillane and I've since
gotten from our esteemed committee
researcher a very nice document to that
effect
126 accrual date that is accrual not a
cruel
date for child support payments also
representative Spillane 124
temporary alimony representative D
Simone
547 rebuttable presumptions of sole
custody determinations representative
Testament
and then for hearings I put down at 11
o'clock
did we exec it
we did
where was I
that's worse it'd be better if I wasn't
I think
I was frozen okay
all right
yeah thank you all right that'll go on
consent I agree hearings 11 o'clock HB
491 the prohibiting of restraints
representative is it Muse pronounced
m-e-u-s-a Muse okay
and then 115 notice you're getting a
little longer lunch hour reunification
therapy representative
306 is what I have
then two o'clock HB 49 modifying the
definition of neglect representative
Corcoran and 245 HB 551 dcyf tracking
and Publishing of stats
representative Corcoran
so
that's on the agenda
I opened the executive session on House
Bill 120 and the chair will entertain a
motion to retain
representative long
thank you Mr chairman I'll move to uh
retain uh
Hospital 120. is there a second right
here Simone
and as we've explained before sb1 is the
platform that's going to drive this and
HP 120 is in reserve in case we need it
there being no further discussion the
chair will call the role on House Bill
120 FNA the motion representative long
motion to retain second and
representative D Simone
and you know how they often say no
celebrations in the gallery well in this
case I'll entertain the people in the
gallery doing the wave
go
chairman clerk may call the roll
Jim and Pearson yes
representative long yes
representative DeSimone yes
representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball
representative Panic is absent
representative Seidel yes
representative Grossman is absent
representative Levesque yes
representative Petrino will be voting
yes
representative Perez yes representative
Greg yes
representative Moulton yes
representative Raymond yes
retain passes 14-0 with two absent
thank you
excessive celebrations are now welcome
this closes the exact session on House
Bill 120. thank you everybody have a
good rest of the week
no we don't have Raymond's uh wasn't it
worth coming over